I wasn't always confident walking across
the room but what I had were parents who
told me not to let my fear guide me
so they continued they they started
pushing me early out of the nest to try
new things walking to school you know
yourself
it's the basic things that a parent can
allow their child to do that starts
building confidence so I tell the story
about me being in kindergarten and my
mother we lived in around the the corner
from our school on Euclid Avenue and
went to the neighborhood public school
and my mother decided okay here's an
alarm clock it's time for you to wake
yourself up and you can walk around the
corner to school
was like a lady are you crazy I am five
years old I didn't say that but that's
what was going through my little mind
um but I did it and the lesson that I
learned from her is that she had to
overcome her fear of letting me go
and a lot of times as parents we hold on
tight for too long